how are you doing sir I'm all right I'll
hold this up for you okay uh I have I
have two questions with you and I
actually am overwhelmed by this because
okay so where I guess my big thing is uh
you it's 12 episode season two have you
finished writing all 12 Scripts
I have three weeks to finish the final
on the last one I have finished 23 of 24
scripts I have another 30 days before
the writer's Guild strike to finish
what is yeah episode episode three will
be the last one I write weirdly so that
is very so apparently that'll be my last
final yes episode three
um can you talk one of the things about
the making of on the plane I'll be
working on it tomorrow
one of the things about making any TV
show is that the first season you're
learning the infrastructure of how to
make the show what have you what has it
been like making the second season what
did you learn on the first that you've
applied to season two that's really
helped you or Amplified something or do
you know what I mean
Oh you mean the production institutional
matter well look we have the person
who's not here who really deserves so
much credit is Donna Wallenberg who's
the producer of the show and the team
that we built out there I mean literally
it's like 1400 people that are out there
but the core group of all the department
heads and the directors that we brought
in it's we have an Institutional memory
of of quality of everybody being a
filmmaker of every good idea being
raised people raise their hand people
speak up everyone has respect and we
have a really happy motivated obsessive
bunch of people and we we you know we
did that through covid last time in a
crippled fashion now we have a a much
more organized I just I'm trying to say
is we we built a system that um
that we're very proud of and and a
working group that we're really proud of
so our institutional memory is really
strong so we don't we try not to make
the same mistakes we made before we try
to benefit on what we learned before
we know how to do it now we know how to
do it I'm curious for fans can you tease
any of the new characters that are going
to be in season two I cannot I'm not
it's so long out I can't do that sure
I'm just looking yeah
we got to do this again next time and
I'm still not going to be able to show
you we'll be next start we'll be selling
it's only said on the stage that the
goal is for August I think you made a
mistake I just meant with the previous
release the original release was that
August and then we got moved to
September so I think it'll probably be
Mike I don't have a date but my guess
will be the same usually Studios like to
do things the same way they did them
before so my guess is
September August that period of time
we'll be done with the show it'll be
ready by then yeah so basically it's
also could be determined on when how
things go with VFX and everything else
yeah we have a year to do it I mean
well we we're budgeted to do it on that
schedule I suppose you could do it
faster if you want to but I don't think
there's any more money to do it that way
so I can already see that I'm gonna get
the hook I'm just going to say listen
thank you thank you and I have a million
other questions but when when we have
more time I'll see you soon